this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host anthony o'neil
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life
and your money it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five and some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it
jeff is with us in birmingham hey jeff
how are you
i'm doing well dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up in your world
so my wife and i are currently on baby
step three we have right at three months
of expenses saved up
we have a potential move on our hands
i've got a job opportunity
potentially coming up in april and may
and we also
she has a 20 year old car we're looking
to replace
and we just found out two weeks ago she
is expecting our first child so
hey yeah we're very excited but we're
just curious
what is your advice on the next step
should we begin uh baby step four yet
should we hold off and start saving for
those things
what should we do wow well i mean
all three of them are predictable events
and so we should save in addition to an
emergency fund because
they're not really an emergency since
they're predictable yeah yeah yeah
absolutely how much do you think it
would take you to move jeff
is your job going to give you a moving
allowance
it potentially will but i don't know
that exact figure yet
so that there is some some cash there
that i might be able to get i think
possibly up to about a thousand dollars
in moving expenses sounds good
i wouldn't worry about the car right now
i heard you said you went to uh going
ahead and replace that eventually i'm
not worrying about the car
um if i am you i am moving on to babysit
for and i am starting the the investment
process
but also at the same time like dave said
i am gonna be focusing on saving for the
baby
um and then finding out if i am gonna
get some moving expenses for my company
if not
then yes you may pause babysit four so
you can go in ahead and prepare
to move uh because that is a priority
that is a must
yeah when you add all three of these
things together what's going to come out
of pocket for the move and out of pocket
for the baby
in particular uh i'd want to make sure
you have
that yeah in addition to your emergency
fund but before you move on to baby step
four
uh but buying the car i think you can
probably save up four
to do to do that and that car will make
it a little while
it didn't suddenly become old it was
already old three months ago before you
got all these other pieces of
information
right so um you know you do want to you
do want to again
budget to pay cash for it so you don't
end up with another stupid car payment
right
absolutely absolutely well i will tell
you uh
this is breaking news we have not told
anybody so i'll just let you know you're
the first one to know that we're
expecting our first child
ah you should have told your parents
before you told anthony
yeah because i'm gonna tell the whole
world you know i'm just letting you know
right now just told 21 million people
dude
that's it well congratulations
we are planning to do that this weekend
just our schedules haven't allowed for
it
oh no you you need to call them uh it's
too late they've already heard it
well congratulations we're so proud for
you man that's awesome and yeah
uh so babies first travel or move is
second
and car is third and depending on your
household income
how quickly you could pile up enough
money to take care of those i might
pause a little bit
and let's just get ready for a known
situation
the beautiful thing is is you're
actually thinking about all this and
doing it intentionally it's not
happening to you you're happening to it
yes sir and dave i don't have any kids
but you do
so you know when i have my first child
is it safe to say about
five to ten grand is a good extra
cushion for a baby
it depends depends on what your
insurance is going to cover uh
you know health insurance with this
company will cover the labor and
delivery
right uh and what's his deductible and
does he have an hsa and
you know what's out of pocket um if
you're paying cash for it yeah you would
need that okay you'd need 10k
probably in today's world uh and
you know you if you do not have
insurance for labor and delivery but
most places do nowadays
yeah and uh most most policies do and so
uh you know what's your co-pay what's
your deductible and you can calculate
and get an estimate what you're
out of pocket is going to be not what
the total cost is because that doesn't
matter
gotcha what matters is what you're going
to have to pay and then
uh and you got nine months to get ready
for that apparently or eight
and uh um
then we've got a you know we've got a
thousand dollars will not move you
right and so if you got a five thousand
dollar move you got another four
thousand there
right and so if you're making a hundred
thousand dollars a year you can do this
real quick if you're making fifty
thousand dollars a year
you're probably going to take a few
months to get ready for all of these
things that are coming at you
yeah that's what you're facing way to go
man very cool
sean is in pittsburgh hey sean how are
you
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can we help
so four years ago my wife and i bought a
house in
colorado that turned out to be a big
mistake because we couldn't afford it we
bought too much house
and we ended up selling it two years
later made about 30 grand profit off of
it used it to sell
to get rid of all the debt we had and we
moved out to west virginia
where i got a job as a youth pastor and
now that job has kind of
ended and we're looking at moving back
to colorado and i was wanting to ask you
if it would be a good
idea um our plan here we're thinking
about moving in
with my parents that live right next to
uh
where we work in colorado remotely right
now we're
thinking about moving in with my parents
and living their rent free
to save up a bunch of money for a little
while and then buying a lot of land
and then using that land as collateral
to get a loan to build a house
instead of buy one outright because of
the market out there the houses are so
expensive we're like well we could
probably
save a bunch of money and have tons of
equity in the house already if we just
built one instead of buy one
so sean let me ask you a couple of
questions before dave jumps in here
uh you said you're working remotely so
are you no longer pastoring and
are you doing you're doing something
else
yeah so uh the the youth pastoring job i
have here
is um i feel like god's calling me on
just
other things in colorado to move back
there and so i put in my notice that
i'll be leaving
in july when my lease is up at our
apartment here in west virginia and
we're going to be moving back to
colorado and what will you be doing and
how much money will you all be making a
year
so um i will be pursuing a new job to
like make more income but right now
what we will be making my wife and i
together will be about
um 60 to 65 a year
okay cool so here's my answer real quick
before we go to our commercial break
uh no i don't want you to go back in
with your parents and i and i don't even
want you to get a piece of land
right now you need to go ahead and just
get a solid foundation
i would go rent an apartment and then
follow the baby steps from there because
it sounds like you don't have three
months in your emergency fund already
correct
yeah yeah so get an apartment live below
your means
and go on the heck you said you paid off
all your debt get your three to six
months set aside
then you and your wife can start looking
at land down the road
we don't need to move into your parents
house skip over baby step three they go
buy a house you're gonna be right back
in the situation you are today
so get an apartment get three months and
you'll be straight
yeah that's exactly right the um the
idea of buying a piece of land and
building a house and having a bunch of
instant equity is not
it's not to work out that way when you
finish building a house you're going to
have
almost in it what you would have had had
you bought a house
that's what it costs to build a house
and so
you don't get like a 50 discount because
you built from the ground up it doesn't
work that way
so no i think you i think anthony's
right you need to get a little apartment
and get your jobs and your careers
solidified
and then start gradually working your
way back into home ownership at that
point
that's going to be your best bet
[Music]
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at
chministries.org backslash
budget
[Music]
[Applause]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host
today i am dave ramsey your host thanks
for joining us on the ramsay show
emily is with us in green bay wisconsin
hi emily welcome to the show how can we
help
hi um so my husband and i got married
in november and we've been talking about
having a baby not right this very second
but sometime in the near future but
all these numbers that you see everyone
says it's so expensive like hundreds of
thousands of dollars
so and i'm a planner so i'm just
wondering how do we decide if we are
financially prepared for a baby uh
you are yeah i was about to say if it's
a hundred thousand dollars to have a
baby emily i'm never having a baby
those numbers are are
stretched and they really mostly come
into play
if you get into a super large family but
if you have a couple of children the
vast majority of your electric bill does
not change
your water bill changes a little but not
that much
your food bill will change some but not
that much
first couple of years you've got some
formula and diapers and other things
mandatory pediatrician bills that
uh come at you and that kind of stuff uh
we always joked and said
it's mandatory it's federal law in the
first three years of a child's life to
pay the pediatrician's porsche bill
but they don't really make that much
money the pediatricians don't but it's
still fun to mess with them but the um
uh yeah so you're gonna have some costs
but the idea that you need to have 200
000
in the bank before you have a child is
absolutely ludicrous no or will you
realize over the scope of their life
that you spent 200 000 on them no you
won't even realize it
because it's just like you know we get a
little bit more macaroni
we get a little bit more uh another
six-pack of coca-cola or whatever i mean
you just whatever it is that the family
eats they're just gonna eat it
and so you know if you're asking the
question out loud you probably can
afford it
okay yeah have a baby emily
we don't we do not have never in the
history of
ramsey solutions told someone to have a
child or not have a child based on
their financial situation yeah now
obviously you want to use common sense
and reasonableness and if you're
completely broke and you make
21 000 a year don't have 16 children
it's a problem
you know uh that kind of thing that's
common sense and reasonableness
but you know the typical middle class
family
doesn't have any trouble affording in
air quotes
of their children you're going to be
just fine i agree
i like that answer dave i'm proud of you
on that answer
well thanks i feel better about myself
but you know what dave i i have said
this so tell me if i'm wrong for saying
this i don't believe
in the first six months to a year you
should you should have a baby
of your marriage it should be spent with
y'all two getting to know each other and
figuring out what you're going to do
with your life yeah that's not a
financial equation though that's just a
space
equation and you know most couples do
that
yes um but other couples are um
really excited to have children i know
uh and and that's okay too if you want
to do that i
i we enjoyed a couple years like you're
talking about before denise came along
and um and we've enjoyed every year
since she came along as well so
um uh and none of them were her fault
one way or the other so that's you know
that that's the first baby right but
the um but yeah anytime in any area of
your life money
relationships anything you can give
yourself margin yeah that's a good thing
margin's never a bad thing it gives you
a little it kind of smooths out the
waves of life a little bit
all right milton is in tampa florida hi
milton how are you
hi dave pleasure to speak with you and
anthony this afternoon
sure um my question so um i've been
contributing to my 401k for about 28
years now and just last year
they opted to give us an option of a
roth 401k
so i took that option and i stopped
um contributing to the traditional 401k
and started contributing to my roth
ira good the match is the same on the
raw good as it was on the traditional
good so although although i currently
have about a two million dollar net
worth i figured
anything i can put together tax that
gross tax free would benefit me in the
long run
you are right but my but the question is
can i
roll over the roth portion of my 401k
into my raw ira
yes it will be a different it will be a
technically a different account number
uh but you can always roll over a your
k to your roth ira if you've left the
company are you still working for the
company
yeah i'm going to be with the company
for about another six to eight years you
can't move a 401k while you still work
there
well no that's i was just trying to be
uh trying to get ahead of the game here
to see if
if i would do that when i did leave oh
yeah i wish i would do that yeah
yes i would do that okay because i okay
because i couldn't see the the
difference
it's one account number and it shows my
401k on my statement
right it isn't broken down as to roth
and tradition
right how old are you i'm 54.
how much is in the traditional portion
of your 401k
the bulk of it is about one point
about 1.6 million okay i might begin to
move some of that
into roth and pay the taxes on it now
inside that 401k
okay because let's say you move 500 000
over and you pay the taxes on 100 000
bucks okay
or whatever they come out something like
that 100 and a quarter
will be your taxes before tax rates go
up and apparently they're going to
according to the president he says he's
going to raise taxes
tax rates and so uh on people that have
the kind of money you've got
and so uh before that happens maybe you
move some of it into roth and go ahead
and pay the taxes on it and then let
that additional 500k
grow tax-free from this point forward
so so paying that i wouldn't have i i
don't have the hundred and a quarter i
only have about
60 yeah okay well you don't you don't
need to do it then
you don't need to do it i was thinking
maybe with that kind of net worth you
had some cash outside of retirement but
um no you don't need to do that but
whatever you can afford to move
and pay the taxes with cash out of your
pocket
i would go ahead and begin to move it
inside that 401 t
k 2 roth now when you retire whatever's
roth you can move to a roth and it will
be a different account
number than your current roth ira
but it could be in exactly the same
mutual funds as your current one
okay but rollovers just don't combine
with existing is all technically but
it's just a it's just a
fine line okay i appreciate it
yeah so very cool man you've done great
congratulations
did you you didn't inherit any of this
it's all 401k money so you became
worth 2 million from the ground up
starting with nothing way to go
thank you very much that's impressive
and 54 years old worth a couple million
dollars that's exciting to me dave
that's how it works i mean listen you
can't stop saying you can't be a
millionaire
follow the steps you'll get there he's
not a millionaire
he's a couple of millionaires that's
probably bad grammar but you know
i think we knew what you meant yeah he's
a millionaire two times over right yes
sir there you go
all right a multi-millionaire yes there
we go
i like that's working good i really do i
really do now let's say dave he did have
the cash
would you even say hey go ahead and move
the whole 1.6 over to the roth
if he had the cash it would be very hard
to swallow
okay emotionally but mathematically then
from this point forward
it would all grow tax-free yes that's
going to work out for him
and because he's going to pay taxes at a
higher tax rate
later because the tax rates are probably
going up
yeah if this current president and
congress have their way and i suspect
they will because they all agree on
everything
right so um you know that it looks like
taxes
on evil wealthy people are going up so
then
mathematically it makes sense to do it
now because you save yourself money
if you have the funds to do it right now
if you just take the money
out of the ira i mean like reduce the
1.6 balance by enough to pay the taxes
right then it's a wash mathematically
because that portion you took out would
have grown to enough to pay the taxes
anyway yes
so you would been okay yes but you'll
come out better off
if you've got a 10-year period of time
or more to roll if you can pay it out of
your pocket in other words your baby
steps seven yep
you got extra money laying around he's a
multi-millionaire now you don't need to
fool with that if you're
in baby steps two or three or four or
five whatever and then you're six you
still need to pay off your house first
before you talk about that strategy
yes but any money you can get out of
taxable accounts if you're going to
become wealthy
is going to be a good idea because that
the tax rates are
in the political climate appear to be
going up nope
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on the debt free stage in the lobby of
ramsey solutions justin
and heather are with us hey guys how are
you
hey dave hey anthony welcome where do
you guys live
we live right outside of memphis
tennessee and collierville town oh yeah
about three hours down the road though
yeah that's right welcome to nashville
and all the way over here to do your
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off
just around four hundred and seven
thousand dollars goodness
how long did that take it took a little
over eight years it took a while
okay that works too and your range of
income during that time
we started off around 140 got up to
about 190 for a couple years and then
we're back down
around the 140 range again i went part
time oh okay good for you
well i'm guessing with this amount and
how long it took it must be you paid off
your house
yes sir yeah we did look at it weird
people
that's right what is this what is this
paid off house worth
uh 360 370. wow
it's all yours yeah how old are you two
weirdos
uh i'm 34 and today's her 35th birthday
unbelievable
yeah wow way to go happy birthday
very nice what better way to celebrate
yeah
man baby let's go i love
it man four hundred and seven thousand
and eight years so tell us the story how
did you get started on this and what
happened
well um i went to pharmacy school so
that was
a pretty big chunk of the money that was
about seventy thousand dollars
and he was working at one of your
momentum churches during that time
uh bellevue baptist church and he's
he's a pastor so he was on staff there
and um
they went through your whole program and
he had actually read i think
total money makeover before i was in a
bookstore and saw your face on a book
and i was like
all right i'm gonna get it on a whim and
just read it in spite of the picture
yeah there you go yeah
and uh read it in a morning just i think
i was around 24 or so at the time
yeah and uh kind of went from there
we've been leading fpu classes and we
took our whole church through it last
year
yeah it was just super cool to see um
how god used
you guys in our lives but also in life
for our church because
we didn't know what 2020 was going to
bring yeah and we took our whole through
church through it through 2019 and then
boom and it really helped a lot of
people yeah pastor gaines is a good man
he's a good friend
and we're at collierville first baptist
now and they've gone through it as well
oh wow um but anyway yeah i i just
remember
having this distinct memory taking out
loans in pharmacy school
which i had some help from scholarships
but not enough
but i remember checking my loan balance
and i think i did it like
i checked it one day and then i checked
it the next day and it had gone up like
two or three hundred dollars
in one day and i was like oh my gosh
these have to die
like as soon as i get out of school like
this is just not gonna work
like i'm not gonna keep letting this
pile up on us so
how long you guys been married 13 years
almost wow yeah okay coming up on 13. so
you went through the student loans and
the other day and then you started on
the house the student loan went by
really quick because we just kind of
lived on his salary
um when i got out and so we were just
able to hit that really hard
so that was like a sprint and that was
done i think that's one of the keys
is as you make more money just be
content with what you have
don't just keep increasing increasing
your spending just because you're
getting more money and so we just
that was one of the things that we tried
to do and i got
rachel's rachel's uh the gratitude
journal her contempt journal
and just trying to daily remind myself
just
to be satisfied with what i have and to
be content in that and that kind of
helped along her journey
yeah but the house that was just a
marathon man that just
took takes a while to go from the
consumer debt
to your your mortgage i mean consumer
debt and i'm pretty sure
you did your savings account three to
six months yes but then what
why like why did you want to attack the
mortgage i know that's baby set six but
you're young you're 30 you're in your
30s your 20s like yeah
why what was the thought process behind
that well one of the things
when you go through fpu you go you go
through it with people in different life
stages
and i saw and heard so many stories of
empty nesters
who would say i wish i had this in my
20s and 30s yeah
and they were speaking wisdom into our
life of saying if you do this now you'll
be more free later
and that's kind of how i viewed it as
not holding my future
kind of in chains but being being
fiscally responsible so that in the
future i could do whatever the lord
calls me to and i'm not
bounded by debt and so that's kind of
helped us over the last few months as
we've been out of debt is we can now
give more to things that we're
passionate about
and uh and when a water line busts in
your house you're not freaking out
because you know you've prepared for it
so it's so good
and you can go part time with a house
full of kids yeah that's yes that's been
huge
that's been huge big lifestyle change
and it's because we've worked the
program
honestly you've led fpu you've paid off
your home at 34 years old you've done it
all you're absolute heroes
tell people what the key to getting out
of debt is
again i would say being content um
and then just sticking with the budget
and working the plan
it's kind of a bad plan is better than
no plan at all but this is a good plan
and i always tell people you know when
it comes to fpu
i'm not a paid salesman i'm a satisfied
customer and i just tell people you know
just work it and give it time and
you know you say it's uh we're we're in
the crock pot business not the microwave
business and
you know it's tough and i would just say
like if there's anyone out there
who maybe you're beginning this kind of
whole process i just want to encourage
you because
um it's going to take some time and it's
hard but it's worth it
and having been on the tail end of this
just encourage people that it's worth
the work
you're going to be free and you're going
to be able to give like never before and
you're gonna have freedom and it's it's
great
so over the eight years what was the
hardest thing that you two had to
get over i don't know
um well you never want to get in the
comparison game of comparing yourself to
other
people yeah because even when she was in
a pharmacy school
there were people buying like mercedes
and just taking out more and more loans
and
we're just thinking you are crazy for
doing this and uh
and to say you know but what i've seen
is
what's helped us anthony is god has just
been so faithful
throughout the whole time and he's
provided for all of our needs and
i just i'm i'm a believer that when
we're faithful to him
uh he's faithful to us and you reap what
you sow
and so part of it is just sticking with
the plan and
um putting your big boy pants on and
just getting after it
and it works it works you guys were
obviously very unified in the process
too
yeah i mean i'm the spender so there
were definitely some times when i was
not happy
about not being able to do something but
um now you can do anything
yeah within reason but yes
you got no freaking house family i'm
just saying
wow that's so impressive you guys are
amazing
very very well done and you brought the
kiddos with you to do the debt-free
screen what are their names and
ages uh madeleine is our first she's
seven
and anna kate is five mm-hmm and little
truman is
a coven baby he's one all right go
truman
matching shirt with dad that's right
baby that's awesome man
well done well we got a copy of chris
hogan's book for you everyday
millionaires that's definitely the next
chapter in your story thank you for
leading financial peace through your
church and thank you for doing this
stuff
absolutely i'm so proud of you guys very
very well done
thank you all right anna cape madeleine
and truman are you ready to scream
so yeah ready are you ready all right
we're going to count it down justin and
heather from memphis tennessee
407 000 paid off in eight years making
140 to 190 to 140
house and everything 34 years old
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one we're dead
[Music]
[Applause]
fabulous oh man that's perfect
that that young family and they don't
have a house payment that's gonna be so
much money in 20 years listen making
that kind of income these are definitely
millionaires within the next few years
yeah
and they know how to control it and
they've completely reformed
yeah their brains renewed their minds as
the bible says
yes be not conformed to this world but
be transformed
by the renewing of your mind and that's
what they did it's absolutely incredible
very very very well done what an
inspiration and those little kids man
their lives are changed forever oh for
sure
and their kids yeah that's dead three
kids yeah i mean this is uh
incredible they're gonna be in such a
completely
different place stuff we teach works
guys
it works it's that simple yeah wow
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
well tax season is upon us i know try to
contain your excitement
nobody likes doing taxes especially
after a year like 2020 it is a hassle to
begin with
but then you go look for help and these
so-called free tax software tools get
you knee deep in the filing process
and then sucker punch you with add-on
fees and credit card pitches and try to
get you a mortgage
or worse than that try to sell you a uh
refund loan where they loan you the
money for your refund
early oh my goodness and they're too add
up the interest rate on that baby
well there's a better way to do it none
of those gimmicks it's simply called
ramsey smart tax
this is our team's brand new tax filing
software that will help you file with
confidence
and with ramsey smart tax you get
upfront pricing
at a very inexpensive deal and no tricks
and no trades
and if you're a member of ramsey plus
you can use ramsey smart tax
for free wow check that out
so text the word tax to 33 789
check out ramsey smart tax by tax
texting
tax to 33789
quinn is with us in denver hi quinn how
are you
i'm doing good how are you doing dave
better than i deserve what's up
hey so i'm in baby step two
i still owe 80 on my student loans i
started at 120
i paid off 40 last year making 50.
good for you and i have some medical
issues
i had like five surgeries uh when i was
going through high school and college in
my left knee
and i no longer have cartilage in my
left knee and i need to get these very
expensive shots they're about you know a
thousand dollars a shot
one one a week for three weeks every
nine to 14 months
and i was curious how do i plan that
into my budget where do i do
the second option my doctor is giving me
which is a ten thousand dollar stim
what is it called the stem cell
treatment um how do i plan that into
into my budget um so that i can uh not
be in as much pain as i am walking
around
wow i'm sorry that's awful what do you
make
you said 50. you said 50. yeah i make i
make around 50. i make a lot of overtime
so i made like 58 in overtime last year
so what do you do
i'm an engineering project coordinator
for uh med
device and drug r d company
so you're around this stuff all day long
and then you need some of it huh
okay um well i mean
it it sounds i don't know what the uh
probability of the stem cell is is that
a hundred percent does that work all the
time
or is it just a hope it's it's a it's a
uh they say it's not fully approved by
the insurances yet because they're still
doing their
their trials so but the science looks
good when i looked at it because because
i know how to read those papers
yeah but i'm saying if you do this is it
a 98
chance you're going to be okay and never
have to do like a
70-ish percent chance which is very high
yeah and my my understanding of the
world
okay all right i don't know anything
about this i'm just trying to gauge
three thousand dollar shots and pain or
three thousand dollar shots
yeah three three you know three one
thousand dollar shots and pain
regularly versus ten well you break even
after three rounds of that right
yeah and minus the pain and i'm pretty
much a coward so i don't like pain
um so i'm trying to figure out a way to
do that but you got 80 000
of student loan debt left left
[Music]
so if you make it one more year without
doing this procedure
that's going to cost you three thousand
dollars right and
it will move further out of the
clinicals possibly to become ensure
insurance covered right possibly
but you know these things take you know
five to ten years yeah unless
unless it's a coveted vaccine then it
takes about 10 minutes
[Laughter]
um yeah it's interesting how approvals
change on things but the uh
yeah i mean it could it very well it
could be um
is it serious pain uh yeah yeah
yeah it's rather serious uh you know i
don't want to walk on it even you know
minor surgeries whatever somebody else
okay
okay it's all pain yeah yeah i'm trying
to think what i would do in your shoes
knowing that i'm a complete coward and
you're hurting so
i'm trying to empathize i've never had
this exact thing obviously
but um if i'm in that much pain sharon
did do the stem cell thing and it did
work but it was a much smaller
situation than you've got um so
i i don't know um
if i woke up in your shoes i probably
would stop everything and come up with
the 10 grand
you would yeah oh yeah the only other
thing
that comes into my mind is it is more
than interesting to me that you are in
that
in and around that business and i wonder
if
one of your
uh leaders with your current company
knows the leaders with the company that
provide the
other proceed provide the other stuff
and can't get you
some help on the pricing no i already
went down that path i tried some other
things that that my
my boss knew about that were um in
development and those those were pretty
okay
but you know they don't last yeah but
i'm just saying temporary
the uh i guess the is it the actual
injection that is so expensive or just
the procedure itself
the the three shot injection no no no no
the stem cell
the i think it's the
well as this is explained to me they
take a sample
out of my knee and then they grow it in
a lab in boston
and then they inject it back into my
knee after it's grown and that all
comes around ten thousand dollars yeah
and i'm just saying the company that
does all of that
should have a friend working inside your
company
[Laughter]
that's what i'm hoping and i'm just
going to continue to poke around on that
because it's a ten thousand dollar
discussion and if they knock half off or
something because you
you push around try to find one degree
of separation here
one of your bosses knows one of the
bosses over there probably yeah
that's what i'm saying and just go hey
do my guy do my guy a favor here man
and um take care of my guy and the worst
case scenario i've made those phone
calls for people here
not not medical calls but in other
situations where i go hey man you got
that over there would you take care of
my dude yeah i'll take care of him and
then i owe you one right
and that's uh uh if i could figure that
out it would help
speed this up the cheaper this gets the
faster i would do it you know
and so the the uh um but yeah i'm taking
care of your knee man
i mean you need to get this done and um
i don't like the 70
probability but the rest of it i'm gonna
i'm gonna give it a try if i'm in your
shot
in your situation what do you think no i
was saying the same thing dave and even
right now you got a knee done
never never yeah never but uh
i imagine hogan has i'm pretty sure he
has
especially playing football and stuff
like that yeah yeah but
while he's looking at that i'm i'm
starting to save
for the worst case scenario if i got to
pay the full ten thousand dollars yeah
i'm gonna build the ten as fast as i can
during that time i'm gonna work every
phone
and every connection i can to try to get
a better deal yeah uh which gets the
procedure done that much quicker quicker
yeah
that's that's interesting very
interesting discussion
sorry you're going through that man yeah
really that's just open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
misty uh i'm sorry uh brandon
says i just started following your baby
steps the largest debt i have is my
student loans a hundred thousand dollars
should i move this to baby step six
since i do not have a home
no no what what
i'm confused uh if you said student
loans right yeah
no i i'm sorry dave that threw me why
would you ask well because it's a huge
loan it's sometimes bigger than a
house loan and so some people often ask
us you know i want to move it to baby
step six just because it's big
no no it's it's baby step two you guys
yeah
well you're not getting rid of sally mae
even if she's a big
yes big sally mae yes she's a big ugly
woman
don't prolong her no that's a gear she
ain't even ugly that's just
that's just a nasty yeah 100 000
the only way it's going to go away is if
you attack it not if you put it off
right and so um we don't move the babe
we don't move the student loans to
another baby step because of that it's
i've had calls where people said i got
200 000 student loans i owe 60 000 on my
house
you know and they want to move it and
i'm just like no still don't do it no
you still got to attack it and get rid
of it yup that's the thing
fun stuff good hour anthony yes sir
thanks james childs and kelly in the
booth
i'm dave ramsey your host this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the ramsey show where debt is dumb cash
is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host anthony o'neil ramsey
personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today
thank you for joining us america we're
so glad you're here the phone number is
triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight
eight two five five two two five
sarah is with us in lexington kentucky
hi sarah welcome to the day to the
ramsey show how can we help
hi dave and anthony i have a little
question i'm dead
made me my husband debt free we've been
debt-free for three years
i took a traumatic fall in 2019 and
broke my humors down the flight of
stairs and
damaged my knee i've had one knee
surgery and i'm getting ready to have
another one
the my husband's gone four nights a week
and i don't sleep those four nights
because all my bedrooms are upstairs
so we're kind of like in a dilemma and
he didn't even want to be on dave ramsey
nine years ago but now he's turned into
frugal
i think we should sell the house since
we have no bedrooms downstairs
and buy another house in the next over
subdivision
our house will price at 159 and it's
about the highest one in the str
on the two streets and we could add on
to it for like 30
000 but then i don't think we could ever
get our money back out of it
the houses in the next subdivision are
running about 179
[Music]
but we'll probably only clear like 145
on our house
now i have we have 550 000 in 401k
and we have our emergency fund and we
have 16 thousand dollars because i've
been trying to save
to you know put on another house sixteen
thousand that we could put on the house
but we'll still be a little bit short
what'd you say your household income is
our household income during the debt
free was eighty-four but since i failed
it's down to 65.
because in the last two since 2019 i've
only worked like four months each year
because
i failed and they tried to naturally
heal then they did surgery the next year
then now i've had the knee surgery i'm
gonna have to have another one so
i'm only working part-time okay
and so you're talking about a a
one-level house
i'm talking about a one-level house and
i need to stay
in my area because i'm like the provider
for my mother
who has cancer so i need to stay within
like a five mile radius because you know
i'm over there every day
so i you know i probably could find
something cheaper farther away but then
when she calls me in the other night you
know
it's going to take me longer to get to
her yeah like if you move 10 miles away
it would take you five minutes more
more yeah well she's kind of panicky on
that stuff
and honestly the house is well she gets
panicky
i get panicky you're going back into
debt too
yeah well i think we could have it paid
off in a year well then save it up
yeah and just sleep on the couch for the
next year
because i don't sleep upstairs when he's
not there i i literally i what happened
once i got up in the middle of the night
i made the wrong turn
i was disoriented and i went down the
plot affairs and i know that that's
emotional emotional i'm not i'm not
judging your psychological
that's not always yeah i'm saying what
would i do
if i were your husband if i were you
in this situation i completely agree
with your desire to move yes and get
into a one level
i've got no issue with that if you're
within one year of doing that with cash
then do it with cash or move five
minutes
further away and do it with cash and
deal with a 10-minute drive to mama
instead of a five-minute drive
absolutely okay now the other thing is
they make those stair climber things
that you sit in
they're fifteen thousand but i don't
think i'd ever get our money back out of
that no
yeah sarah don't do it i mean i think
you're trying to come up with all kind
of excuses listen to what dave said
you're able to climb the stairs yeah you
just don't want to right
well yeah i mean i'm able but you know
i've i've done headphone knee surgery
you know it's like i'm not arguing with
you you know
and let me just tell you how weird i am
okay
um if it's this important to you
i would move the living room furniture
into the garage and move the bedroom
into your living room
i'm so serious well we are from kentucky
[Laughter]
well i'm from tennessee so i think we
got this figured out we got to figure it
out
it's just for a short time and if it's
that big a deal for you to get something
that's comfortable
i might rearrange something there yeah
on that first level seriously i'd
consider that as a temporary measure
it's not
it's not a five year thing it's like
we're going to go camping for four
months and five months till we get this
money saved up
but i i think you can do this with cash
if you're careful or if you'll just make
slightly different decisions
sarah would you what you really want to
do is when you're facing something like
this and you've got
several very valid things
a one-on-one bedroom i mean i want to
one level
i it's a reasonable request don't you
think absolutely
then but don't put so many other
constraints on it that you can't
make your solution true yes like i have
to be five minutes for mom instead of
ten minutes from mom oh no
see now that one's silly yeah that one's
silly
she could be 15 minutes away yeah and
and still and go move today
right or sleep in the living room for a
year yep
uh or move your bedroom to the living
room for a year
um or go into debt and pay it off in a
year
but i i i don't think that's the way i
would do that in this situation me i'm
telling my wife we're going to move away
15 minutes so we can give you what you
want right now i'll tell you what the
other thing you could do
uh you could sell the house today
absolutely rent it right
and rent a one bedroom yep for a year
yep yeah that's that's even a better
plan
except for the move two times part which
i'd rather have a root canal
but the moon because the move two times
thing's awful but uh but yeah that
that solves the problem very uh except
for the two moves yeah but they don't
have to move in one year dave they can
stay there for you know two three years
and pile up a bunch of kids exactly even
better one day exactly that one level i
keep doing one bedroom one level one
level one level yeah
it could be a one level one bedroom you
know no i mean well for rent
for rent yeah just go that's that might
be your answer i like that answer dave
and uh you can move just about anywhere
if you're renting for a short period of
time
and she can save within five minutes
yeah yeah
that might work that might work that's
another idea
but i think you're so close if it was
going to be five years to solve the
problem
i might solve it differently yes but
because it's one year to solve the
problem
i'm going to figure out a way to push
through that right and avoid the debt
your husband doesn't want to go back
into
his house and everything's paid off i
can empathize with that yeah
and also empathize with you hurting and
you don't want to make you know you
don't want to make a wrong turn in the
middle of the night and start this pro
healing process over again i have no
issue with that at all either
hey folks how do money conversations go
with your spouse are they in
a battle or are they not happening at
all guys you can get on the same page
with money it starts with both of you
committing to a budget every month with
a membership to ramsey plus
you and your spouse get our premium
budgeting
tool every dollar connects to your bank
and both your phones
so everybody knows what's going on
everybody's on the same page
we're working and making changes
together and uh with access ramsey
with access to ramsey plus courses like
budgeting that actually works
you'll learn exactly how to make a
budget you can get a free trial to
ramsey plus
to to start your free trial text the
word trial
to 33789 text trial
to 33 789 and you can get a free trial
ramsey plus it includes financial peace
university
the baby steps tracker and of course the
premium version
of every dollar lots of other goodies in
there as well smart tax is free right
now
get your taxes done free yeah wow
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices and
they make it simple to shop
blinds shades and interior shutters with
easy online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed
perfect fit go to blinds.com and take
advantage of this week's special
[Music]
savings
[Music]
so
anthony o'neill ramsey personality is my
co-host today our question of the day
comes from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure or you pick the wrong
color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from terry
in louisiana she says my father recently
passed away and my mother
received 320 000 in life insurance
she is debt free and says she doesn't
need the money since she has enough
assets to live
a comfortable life i have a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars in student loans
that
that she wants to pay off for me because
she feels like this is what my dad would
want
i want i have started following your
baby steps
and have been gazelle intense for the
last six months attacking my debt
this would get me very close to being
debt-free i want to honor my father and
never be in debt i am feeling torn about
this
do i accept the gift yes
i really do i mean i would definitely
have a conversation with my mom and make
sure
she doesn't feel that you're trying to
force her into it
but i agree if it was my daughter um and
i passed away and left this i
would definitely want the money to help
my family
proceed forward in life and paying off
the debt will be a good steward in my
opinion of that as long as your mom
is taken care of yeah that's what i'm
concerned about
the reason i'm concerned about it is you
didn't tell us that she had how much
money she's got you just said she has
enough to live a comfortable life
right and um some moms a comfortable
life
is a can of soup a day that's good if
her daughter gets all the money and she
barely makes it by because she's
broke yeah good point and she calls that
a comfortable life but she took care of
her daughter
yeah uh so i don't know what a
comfortable life in
air quotes means if it means she's got a
million dollars in a 401k
and this is an extra 320 on top of that
i'll go with that
yeah if it means she can live off of her
social security
and be struggling no at 1200 bucks a
month right
and calls that comfortable so you can
have this money
yeah and wrong answer right no
so i i need a better definition of
comfortable life
but uh if she if she you know
has enough assets to live account so she
has some assets so it's not social
security
but you know what is it what's really
there that's what i want to know
yeah i agree and uh but you know the
more money mom has the more i go with
your answer
yes yeah i would definitely accept it
now the other piece of this is
you cannot give someone
that much money without a gift tax being
imposed
unless you do it properly
and so you need to see your mom needs to
see a tax
attorney or a tax professional to help
her
file what's called the unified estate
tax credit exemption
and she needs to use up some of her
estate
to avoid paying taxes on this because if
she gives you
more than fifteen thousand dollars she's
going to be taxed at
55 percent and so
do not just write somebody a check in
your family for 120
000 the irs comes in and audits you
you're going to get
hammered and so you need to have some
professional tax guidance
and it's a very simple form and it's
called the unified
estate tax credit and you need to do
that to avoid the gift tax if you guys
go forward with this
and we only go forward with this if
mom's definition of
comfortable is really comfortable yeah
really really really comfortable
yeah tracy is in tacoma washington hi
tracy welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave longtime listener and fan thanks
for my call for taking my call
sure how can we help alrighty so my
husband and i owe 160 000 on our house
and we currently have a hundred thousand
dollars
cash so we thought about refinancing but
our previous loan person said it's best
to do a credit union loan as rates would
be lower and you don't have to pay
closing
so it will only be like a 60 000 loan
they're right
so i was wondering what you would do
they gave me like a ton of different
options it's pretty overwhelming and
just as a side note my husband has ms so
we have
you know our six month fund and
everything like that so we're just
trying to get our
monthly payments as low as possible in
case something was to happen with his
diagnosis
your husband has what uh multiple
sclerosis
oh oh ms okay yes i didn't hear you how
long has he had that
um about a year okay all right and
what's your household income
um well it's about 55 000
after taxes my husband where did the
hundred thousand come from
um just random family gifts and then we
saved
uh a lot you've done well done very well
and you're 100 debt-free except your
home
correct your loan officer is giving you
excellent advice
absolutely okay good let me walk you
through a couple of things to watch for
okay when a credit union or a local bank
makes a loan like this
it's a loan they are going to keep at
the bank
they're not making it by underwriting
guidelines of fannie mae or fha
it's called a portfolio loan they're
going to keep it in their portfolio
okay so it's kind of like a home equity
loan in a sense
they're going to keep it there they're
going to keep it there at the bank
okay so as long as you know that then
that what that tells you is
that whatever rules they want to make up
they can do yeah okay so this idea that
somehow they have to conform to some
other guidelines is a bunch of crap
and so here's what you are going to make
them do what's this house worth
um it's worth 325. okay so a 60 000
loan on a 325 000 house is what's known
as a no freaking brainer right
unless you've got horrible credit or
you're in bankruptcy okay
so what you are going to demand is three
things
okay one is no closing costs
of any kind under any circumstances
okay they need to put they need to do
this to get this loan
two is a fixed rate
okay and three is
a fixed term
do you want a 10-year or a 15-year
probably a 10 will be fine in this case
but you do not get a traditional home
equity loan where the rate floats
and thereby the length of time that
you're in the loan floats and some of
those even have
balloons or calls after three years or
five
years okay you don't want any of that
you want a 10-year
loan that pays off in 10 years that's
called a fully amortizing loan
at a set rate with no closing costs
there is a local bank or credit union
that will be happy
to make you that loan okay cool
you're gonna have to push back though
because they don't always use their
brains at the bank you know that
i do i'm a mom so i'm used to pushback
yeah so i think
okay they're gonna go now you need to
get a home equity loan and this is our
home equity loan product and i'm going i
don't care what your home equity loan
product is
if you want this loan it's going to be
these three things
okay perfect well thank you so much dave
thank you so much anthony
you guys have a great day you too you
too great job by that
loan officer telling them that's a good
loan officer told him not to make a loan
with him
dave i was shocked that's good that's
good integrity i like that because it's
a 60 000
home loan with a traditional mortgage is
super expensive
right and the mortgage companies don't
want to screw with it and they're
they're going to run the
rate up number one if they do screw with
it because it's so small
and they're probably going to hit you
with a bunch of extra side fees uh that
don't need to happen so when you're
making a ver a small loan like that
under 75 000
uh especially where there's a bunch of
equity yeah always go to your local
credit union always go to your local
bank and always remember those three
things i told you no closing costs fixed
rate
fully amortizing fixed term i've seen
some credit unions dave do it
uh below a hundred thousand oh they will
they'll do it alone yeah yeah they'll do
it they'll do a loan over
over over 75 000 yeah but when you get
75 000 and under a traditional fha or
fannie mae loan
becomes unwieldy it's very expensive got
you and most of the
most of the mortgage companies don't
want to screw with that yeah but the
credit unions will
and the you know local bank will
especially in a situation like this so
very very well done good good job of
that loan officer that's good stuff
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host number one best-selling author
the phone number here at the ramsey show
is triple eight
eight two five five two two five
kevin is with us in san diego hi kevin
how are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
so anyways i appreciate you guys for
taking my call
um a little back story i just recently
separated from the military
i did about 10 years currently i'm a
full-time student utilizing the
post 911 gi bill i also just recently
took
a government contracting position full
time in san diego
which pays about 60 thousand dollars
annually good
my wife is a registered nurse but uh we
just had a baby back in january so she's
a stay-at-home mom for now
uh anyways um my question is regarding
uh
equity in our mortgage uh we owe about
300 000
uh and our house is currently worth
about 450.
um my wife and i are almost debt free
we've paid off uh almost 60 000 of debt
but my question is would it be smart to
take out about 20 or 30
000 in equity out of our mortgage to pay
off the rest of the debt
and possibly upgrade some things in the
home no
it wouldn't be that's not a wise move at
all
again and you set the numbers i don't
miss your hearing correctly what's your
household income right now
60 60 all together okay cool and you
said
you have about twenty thousand dollars
in debt
uh about yeah about that yeah yeah
yeah i'm i'm not touching the home loan
i'm not the home law i'm not touching
the equity at
all um what i'm doing is i'm trying to
come up with a game plan and i got this
20
000 cash so kevin thank you for your
service
um your wife is at home with a new baby
and she's standing around inside that
house looking and seeing everything that
needs to be fixed
and that's what started that's what
started this conversation
it did
[Music]
i was afraid i read that right oh my
gosh and so
uh yeah the answer is no babe when you
are able to get back to work we'll be
able to do these this list of things
after we've gotten out of debt and have
our emergency fund in place
yeah so uh you cannot borrow your way
into abundance
yeah i i i understand
um i do receive a housing allowance
through the 911
the post 911 gi bill you get that
whether you do these repairs or not
yeah so instead of taking out would it
be smart just to use that
money uh now it'd be smart to use that
money to get out of debt like every
other piece of money you've got
yeah because you're in baby step two and
you're knocking the debt out you got a
brand new baby we're trying to get out
of debt
how much is your housing allowance kevin
um the housing allowance is about three
thousand dollars but you get that no
matter what you you can do with it what
you want to do with it
come on man so now we're at 78
that's what i'm saying in household
income right yeah
now you're out of nowhere i'm sorry 36
did you say three thousand three
thousand dollars a month right kevin
yeah three thousand uh of housing
allowance oh i'm sorry now we're at 96
000
household income now we're out of debt
in five months
yeah and then you save up and do the
repairs what's the uh what's the cost on
the repairs gonna be
um
rough numbers probably around ten
thousand dollars okay so here's the
thing
you have a ninety six thousand dollar
income you need thirty thousand dollars
you should be done with both of these
in one year without borrowing a dime
okay
okay so um now
what we've got to do is walk through hit
this what happens
is uh the p that
very few people uh look at
a situation like this and and and
they're
really doing a bunch of math and they're
really thinking about how it's going to
turn out 15 years from now they're more
thinking about the here and now
yes and that's what drives you to ask a
question like do i borrow money to fix
up a house while i'm still in debt
and answer to all of it of course is no
and the reason we answer the question we
did is
what helps kevin and his wife and new
baby
be in the best place 10 years from today
not 10 days from today not 10 months
from today
10 years from today what is best for you
and your family
what is going to put you in the most
money situation
and that is to have avoided the debt and
paid cash
for the repairs and have paid off your
existing debts yes
and that's going to continue to free
money up and continue to give you
options
and continue to do these things and it's
just a normal thing for her to be
sitting at home
you know she's you know she's dealing
with a human that can't talk back to her
all day
and so um that is highly needy
and uh and so it's in human nature to
walk around and go well we need to paint
that we need to fix that
and didn't even notice it before come on
now
and that's just normal there's nothing
wrong she didn't do anything wrong but
that's
shorter term thinking and we need to
think what's best for this child
long term 10 years 20 years out yes sir
yes and if you put it through that
paradigm
that's how anthony's quick answer as
soon as you ask a question was no
no with no explanation
zero not a chance no
all right elise is with us in buffalo
new york
hi elise how are you better than i
deserve how are y'all
just the same how can i help yes so
um my question is me and my husband are
on
baby step two right now and
um we're looking uh to be finished in
october and then you know we'll do baby
step three and then we'll start
interviewing some smartvestor pros
and i've read like um chris huggins
retire inspired
and everyday millionaire both um awesome
books
but one of the things i guess i'm
thinking is kind of
for us like let's if we're cuz we're
about 25 and so we're wanting to
like learn from our smart investor pro
but i mean wouldn't if we're
the type of people who like we're not
gonna pull out you know our money from
retirement it's just going to sit there
from like
you know 25 to 65 or 70. would we
need to have a smart investor pro for
like more than a year or two if they're
just going to be like
teaching us i don't know like how to do
investing then we'll be able to learn
from them and kind of like
take it from there yeah well you're not
paying them a monthly fee
anyway or even a flat fee per year to do
your financial planning or something
you're
you're basically taking care of your
financial planning needs
the smart vista pros in your corner to
help you make a purchase
or you to do an investment if you needed
to if you need to do a rollover because
one of you changed
jobs or something like that or for
advice
and on a particular situation something
comes up and you go hey what about this
and so i uh as an example like you say
i'm kind of in the rhythm
of steadily investing and i don't have i
don't have some kind of big meeting with
them
uh every three weeks or something if i
need something i call my guy and i say
hey or i sent him an email i said listen
this is what i'm thinking
got any ideas and he'll send me back a
few ideas and maybe a few things to
purchase that would do that
and then we'll execute that purchase or
we won't
you know i do my backdoor roth iras i
just finished them up the other day
for this year and uh um you know so i
have contact with them during that time
but i don't sit and go over my
statements with them every year
uh they're not that complicated you know
uh you can if you've got questions but
the main thing a smart investor pro does
is they're just it they're there and
available and in your corner
and you just need to kind of have these
professionals
at the um at the tip of your fingers at
the you know at the end of an email or
the end of a phone call that
a text that can get back to you and give
you an answer that's good dave and
you know what's so funny with my
financial advisor i told him i was
trying to build my dream home in the
next three years and he's one who told
me hey
set up for parking your money in the
savings account this was two years ago
he said start parking
in the mutual fund then i heard you talk
about it so financial advisors are just
good people to go to
to get advice for anything any situation
yeah but you're not it's not like you're
paying um
a daycare to watch your kids or
something i mean this or hiring a
full-time
governess for your children uh this is
more like
uh someone that gives you parenting
advice once a year
that kind of a thing yeah so you're
you're thinking about it correctly
you've got the right mindset about it
but they still need to be there
available to you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for joining us america anthony
o'neil is
our co-host today ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
book
debt-free degree you want to go to
college
and not have any debt oh it can be done
you may not like all the choices some of
them include hard work on your part but
he will
show you exactly how to do that with a
debt free
degree tony is in dallas hi tony welcome
to the ramsay show
hi good afternoon dave financing uh
thank you very much for taking my call
sure what's up i do have a question
um regarding my mortgage and a situation
i'm in
i'm just thinking about kind of the
future if i should save up to refinance
or just sell the home
currently on baby step number two um and
expecting
to hopefully pay that uh be out of debt
three by the end of this year
but right now we're on a pause because
we're expecting the baby boy
uh in the late may good for you thank
you
thank you thank you and so right now the
only thing is um
our home we have a 30-year term fha loan
with even down payment assistance um and
so
our payment is around 2200 with
income bringing in 50 300 so that's our
monthly income coming in
so i know when i first bought the home i
wasn't
into your apartment or anything like
that a couple months later that's when i
started hearing you and then i kind of
made a
a situation i realized you know what i
got to live and learn
so now i'm trying to just find the best
way of doing going about this mortgage
tony is that 5300 gross or net
uh that is gross oh so you're bringing
in about forty four hundred
dollars net then no no no no no sorry
okay okay
okay and you said your your house
payment is how much again twenty two
hundred so it's close to that
i mean fifty percent almost but um we
are expected
an income increase uh in august
my uh my wife is going to complete her
teacher certification so
we're going to see her income double
what other debt do you have right now
tony
just fourteen thousand dollars of uh
student loans so what is her income
gonna be then
what is your total household in wait i'm
sorry let me try this again what's your
total household income going to be
after she gets her certification so
after that whenever she gets her
teaching job
which i think we're hoping for august
i'm thinking
in around 6 800 from 6 500 6800 just
defending the area where she works
okay all right and so that puts you at
about 30 percent
yes so a little high and what do you do
for a living
uh and i work in insurance in insurance
yes so uh how much do you project your
income will go up over the next three
years
uh over the next three years hopefully
right now
which is a good time i was thinking
about getting a part-time job
uh but right now since the storms hit in
texas
i'll see they may pull me aside to do
overtime and help out in the claims
section
of our company so that's where i kind of
what are you doing there what do you do
in the insurance world
i'm actually a trainer so i train people
how to oh okay so you're not
you're not selling insurance so your
income's not following a sales pattern
okay so both of you are going to be
getting plus or minus this overtime
uh normal cost of living plus or minus
raises right
yes yeah okay so you're going to be at
30 percent and dude
you're gonna have it tight for a couple
years until it gets down to that 25
percent because your income continues to
go up
i don't think the house is going to kill
you because her income is going to add
to the thing right now um but
uh the the main point of the 25 is if
you're going to be there for 10 years
yeah you're going to struggle if your
house payment's 50 of your take-home pay
but it's not going to be but for a
matter of months
yeah i agree yeah that's what i was
thinking as well i was just debating on
that
um i was like i know it's going to be
tight and i told my life it's going to
be tight a little bit yeah and
i get now with the 25 rule of why it is
yeah so you know because you're feeling
you're feeling the pinch in your budget
right now
oh yeah yeah for sure let me ask you
this question
when you have the baby is she coming
home or is she still going to work
oh she's still going to work well good
thing right now we kind of planned it
this way
she's having the baby late may okay so
she's going to have the whole summer off
okay with the baby and then i do i get
like six weeks paid time off so i'm
going to take the first
probably the whole month of august off
while she goes back to work when
the new school year uh oh that's good
i'm dead that's good oh yeah
okay cool you got a plan so the point is
it's not a forever thing it's for a for
now thing
and the other point is for our listeners
we would not have signed you up for this
trip but you're going to be okay taking
it
okay that makes sense yeah hey man
thanks for the call
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five nathan's in
houston hi
nathan how can we help hey dave and
anthony thank you
for taking my call sure um i have a
question about
when it's okay and how much to
possibly spend on upgrading my wife's
wedding ring
i i've heard you talk about upgrading
vehicles which are a little bit more
practical
and depending on who you ask this might
not might be practical
but um i so my wife and i are going to
celebrate 15 years coming in april
and uh we're we're four
babysit four five and six okay um and
how much would you spend on the upgrade
that that's kind of what i was wondering
um i was
thinking maybe in the 20 to 25
thousand dollar range what's your input
uh like 325 on average
and you're going to pay cash flow great
oh for sure
um that's fine i got i guess
i didn't know when okay yeah let's
just pose it another way okay let you
remember when they used to have these
things called cruises
that's right yeah back before the
pandemic i mean let's say that you for
15 years you wanted to spend 25 000
cash and go on a cruise a luxury luxury
luxury
around the world cruise or something and
that was the way you were going to
celebrate the 15th and you had the cash
and you make 325 and you're on baby step
four
i would say do that okay yeah in other
words if you consumed the money and got
nothing to show for it but a memory
which is what travel is right right
and then i would still say okay because
you have the money as a ratio of your
income
so this is a consumption now what you
don't want to do is call me up and tell
me how diamonds are a good investment
because that's a bunch of crap
no i do i hear you talk about that often
it was just
it was one of those things that i i'm
having trouble with the
with the amount so i was well if it was
something else though
my point is it's a ratio you can afford
yeah
okay if you said if you told me that
number and then you told me you make
eighty thousand dollars i would be going
uh that's a lot
yeah sure no i understand that yeah no
when we got married it was totally
different yeah
headlight on her finger but she started
out with a 0.23
you can't even see the little speck she
started with not a headlight
my wife's rolling a very similar rate so
yeah
okay well thank you i appreciate it
you've done well sir congratulations
and the whole idea that you're actually
asking the question
yourself the question not to us but
you're asking you're gauging it against
something and anthony i think it's
really important you've worked with
uh lots of wealthy people and so have i
yeah that it's all about a ratio
yes yeah and does it you know if you
just
put that amount of money in the middle
of the table and burned it with a match
does it ruin your life does it affect
your life substantially well that's the
question to ask
and uh if it doesn't then it's an okay
consumption ratio
if it does then you don't do it
absolutely
and with that i mean he's been married
for 15 years so i'm pretty sure his wife
she's worth that investment yeah she
earned it yeah she put up with him
i didn't want to say she deserves it
because i want her to be like i deserve
it
she put up with him hey listen that's
why sharon gets whatever sharon wants
to say the same thing and my wife can
take and take and deal with me for 15
years
she deserves a lot yes a lot
whoa whoa whoa dave whoa whoa whoa calm
down we just gotta get you started
we gotta get you started though whoa
whoa dave i'm working on that man
oh my gosh yeah i mean it's uh
but the thing is it is it's always a
good thing to
give you pause and think about what
you're going to consume yes
giving you don't have to think quite as
much about because you can't really mess
generosity up you want to be wise with
it
yes but um you know investing you know
how much can can you invest too much
yeah no you really can't you know but
you don't have to think about the amount
as much but when you're consuming it
using it for personal gain and personal
enjoyment then you have to need to think
about it and that's a good spiritual
exercise
i love it very well done very well done
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice anthony o'neil
ramsey personality number one
best-selling
author of debt free degree is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five so coming into uh the
opener anthony and i were having an
awful
discussion that i think we probably need
to bring up for everyone else it's a
good
uh i i didn't realize it james my
producer had sent me an article from
forbes i was reading at the break
at the top of the hour and um that that
biden had said uh president biden had
said in a town hall
earlier in the week that he will not
forgive
student loan debt with an executive
order
he doesn't think that that is
constitutional and correct
a little bit shocking very i'm i'm
personally happy to hear that
yeah um but that means it puts it on
congress to pass
and uh and he said he won't support the
50
dollar forgiveness only the ten thousand
dollar version
yes but the fifty thousand aoc and
elizabeth warren are asking for
it's a 650 billion dollar
price tag now let's keep that in let's
take this out all right so there's 1.7
trillion
yep and student loan debt and that so
that will leave about
a trillion yes if you forgave 650. we
still have a crisis
still have a crisis still have a problem
and
as i've said many times it is
intellectually dishonest
to forgive student loans while you're
still making them
if they're so bad and people are getting
destroyed by the student loans and we
have to come to your
rescue you poor little people and
washington's gonna be there
for you and we're gonna help you out
yeah if that's the case then you need to
stop making the loans stop doing that
and then also too dave
and this may sound selfish but i worked
my behind off to pay off my
student loans it may not have been a lot
uh but it was still ten thousand dollars
so where's your money where's mine
exactly you know i worked hard and it's
not just me i'm pretty sure we have
millions of people listening right now
like hey i paid off twenty five thousand
a hundred thousand you know where's my
money so
you know this is interesting we already
know the republican party is not going
they will not forgive
the loans and then there are some
democrats who are like i don't know
neither
yeah cause they're gonna have people
like you they're going uh hello exactly
i'm gonna be mad at you
because i want my money back exactly you
know you know and so
yeah i think the um i don't know if they
got the votes to do it in congress
i i don't you know what this may be a
political move on president biden's part
oh because if he does it he takes all
the heat yeah
if he puts it off on congress and then
they don't do it or they do do it
they get the heat yep and it's not on
him they get the heat from the left if
they don't do it they get the heat
from the everybody that paid off their
loans and want my money back
if they do do it and so yeah that's why
it may be political cover that might be
real good strategy on his part because
if it does go through then he can say he
has something to do with it
yeah but he didn't feel like it was
constitutional to do it with an
executive order right
and i'm i i was shocked though david i
came back and said that i'm
not going to do 50 000 yeah i
i was shocked whenever i read the
article i said oh
oh okay so you're right yeah
all right so aoc is not in the white
house after all
that's what it comes down to wow very
interesting
very very interesting it's not it's not
just political it is
financial it is economic and there's an
issue of
uh you know you have to if you're going
to be sincere
yeah and i don't disagree that student
loans are a huge problem yeah
you and i are working diligently to help
people with their student loans yeah
yeah and here's my thing
if they're a huge problem quit making
them and that's my thing before we talk
about forgiving
if that is a conversation let's start
let's talk about how do we stop it
from even happening in the future yeah
once we fix that problem moving forward
then let's come up with a game plan of
how we can help the ones who
we've uh talked and talked them into
doing something stupid but until then
why because we'll be right back at 1.7
trillion
if we forgive this amount within the
next five to ten years well you're going
well and you're gonna do it again
exactly because you didn't you didn't
fix the problem exactly you just you
just treated the symptom
yeah no no no no the symptom is a bunch
of people up to their eyeballs and can't
breathe the problem is
making of student loan debt and it's out
of control
it's too high it's too much it's gone on
too long
right and it's just gotten to be where
it's ridiculous yeah
and um but it's very interesting i
you know i know i'm really old at times
when i see things happen in our world
that i never thought i would live to see
dot dot dot happen it sounds like my
grandpa you say
i never thought i'd live to see the day
that was going to happen i'm that guy
now i'm that guy going i never thought
i'd live to see the day that they'd
actually consider this crap you know
that's what
and they are really considered very
considerate i mean i've said on this
show
it'll never happen right it just shows
what i know
nothing i don't know nothing nah dave
but i mean really i never i never
dreamed that the political climate would
get so far
left and so far towards socialism the
government providing all your goodies
that they would actually be
seriously considering doing this and
then it looked like it was a done deal
right and now it's not again right so
it's
very interesting right so the moral of
the story folks is this
anthony and i the ramsey personalities
of the ramsey organization
have committed our lives to helping you
believe and understand
the truth about how life works
which will cause you based on those
beliefs
if you will act on those beliefs it will
lead you towards abundance
yeah if you act on the beliefs that ken
coleman teaches you about careers it's
going to lead you into a better career
if you act on the beliefs that john
dr john deloney shares you with you
about mental health it will lead you to
a more mentally healthy
situation absolutely um which i'm really
enjoying his podcast oh yeah and
if you believe these things it will
cause your actions to occur
if you believe that the government is
going to take care of you
it causes you to not go
cause to take personal responsibility
for your life
which is a key yes for you to become a
to live abundantly absolutely to live in
wealth yeah
and to live a good life you have to take
responsibility for your marriage no
one's going to fix it for you
you have to take responsibility for your
freaking kids
nobody's gonna fix them for you yeah
you know god help the people that are in
classrooms today
because some of you are piss-poor
parents and you send wild animals into
these classrooms and expect these
teachers to manage them
i mean it's ridiculous dave's going in
you know i mean
because it but it's not bringing
abundance right it's not it's not
and it's you know and you know
i was with a lady the other day that
works with teachers she she is a friend
of ours that
is a world-class expert in the education
field
and she was saying you know what
helicopter parents are help parents who
helicopter and fix all their kids
problems
now they've gone beyond that they have
lawnmower parents
i didn't know what a lawnmower parent is
a lawnmower parent cuts the grass out in
front of the child
so they have an easy path oh man that's
different than helicopters
they're cutting the grass ahead of them
so they don't even have to walk on tall
grass
i mean it's just out of control see this
is none of this
personal responsibility is going to lead
you to the greatest dignity
and the greatest abundance in your life
don't wait on anyone else to fix your
life yeah
it's your job that's it dave
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsey to find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here at ramsey solutions we want to
transform
so many lives that disruption spreads
like wildfire across this country
imagine a world where it's weird to have
a student loan
because everyone's assuming the best way
to get an education's pay for it
imagine a world where the majority
people pay cash for their cars
where the credit card is the cigarette
of the financial industry
where you know how to handle marriage
you know how to handle parenting
you've got a career that has meaning
hey ramsey solutions this is why we have
a thousand people in our in our company
to create digital products and services
events and books to transform
your life this is the goal
we have to disrupt to do it at such a
scale that we disrupt the toxic culture
in america
so many people have just completely lost
their way
if you want to join us on that crusade
we're currently on the hunt for software
engineers
ruby on rails java c-sharp run-in tech
not
tech if you're a ux designer an seo
content marketing specialist we'd love
to talk to you
we're on schedule to hire 360 people in
the year 2021
and a lot of them in the digital space
if you're a senior level developer
we actually go home at night
we don't work you 80 hours you're
actually
go home and be with your family and when
you're writing code or you're showing
somebody how to write code or you're
writing a piece of content or you're
doing a piece of creative
it's always being used to change
someone's life it's work that matters
if you want to find out about the jobs
we've got available go to daveramsey.com
click
on dave's hiring on the right-hand tab
and i will tell you it's very tough to
get a job here sure is
it's easier to get on with the freaking
fbi
because we don't want crazy people in
this building we want people in this
building that care
deeply they're good at what they do that
are hot people of high character
high moral fiber because that's who i
want to work beside every day
i don't want to work besides sleazies
and crazies
yes in a lot of places you have to here
you don't have to
it's a group of very smart people of
high character
that work their tail ends off and then
they go home yeah
and we don't work 80 hours a week facts
we go home and so if you're interested
in that
the interview process is difficult i'll
just tell you in advance
it's um there's a guy sitting out here
that just got hard starts monday he's
moving
stuff into his a third floor apartment
we just met his buddies who moved him in
that's good friends right there
move you into your third floor man and
uh but he's just been through the
interview process and he's just shaking
his head like yeah
that's enough already and you know what
though dave i appreciate our interview
process
because it even helps me to know if if
this is a good fit
you know so i mean yeah i mean i i was
on a pod taping a podcast with a friend
of mine a while ago and she said um
you know you guys are freaky over there
and i'm like yes we are
and she goes i mean like you know what
how many times would people just stand
up and walk out of the interview and go
peace out and i said oh they do
sometimes oh yeah
because we are freaky yeah i mean we
don't we don't really
right want to work with crazy people no
sir
you know i don't want the ladies in this
place to be worried about sleazies
sleazy guys you know it needs to be safe
here
and if you can't be that guy then you
don't need to be in here right
you know i'll just you know and it's
easier to find that out during the
interview
than it is to make you move across the
country and then i got to fire your butt
because you're sleazy
right you know don't do that and and so
yeah it's
it's a lot it it it is it's actually
protecting the person because
you know there was a point in my life uh
before i met christ years ago as an
adult
that if i had interviewed at a place
like this i would have been going you
people are nutty i'm not working there
and i would have walked out the door
oh yeah and i would because i would not
have been a fit
and that's interesting i could not have
gotten a job at 22
in this place
[Laughter]
i'm not sure i could have gotten a job
in this place ever but it's a good thing
i own it but yeah
it's tough to get on but i mean if
you're interested guys and you want to
do something that matters just check
dave's hiring we're hiring positions of
all kinds
yeah but certainly tons and tons of
digital and creative
uh positions click dave's hiring at
daveramsey.com
all right janice is with us in colorado
springs hi
janice welcome to the ramsay show hi hi
guys
thanks for taking my call sure um
i have just my house
and i just refinanced it for a 15-year
loan
good i want to pay extra on it is it
best to
pay the extra along with when i pay the
regular mortgage or to pay it like every
like two weeks later yeah do you do it
online on their site
yes do they have a blank on the site
that says principle only additional
principle
yes then it doesn't matter when you do
it right
okay because it will get credited
correctly because a computer is doing it
yeah in the old days in the old days we
used to tell you when you would mail a
check
you remember are you old enough to
remember mailing a check through the
mail
oh yeah mail a check through the mail
for your house payment
if you were going to add a check for uh
if you were going to add to that amount
for
extra principal reduction for paying off
your house faster we would tell you to
send a separate check
in a separate envelope because the
character opening it might not be smart
enough to figure it
out but the good news is the computer is
smart enough to figure it out
and if it says extra principle online or
additional principle
or whatever and you put it in that blank
it's going to go to principle they
really that's not a hard piece of
programming for them to do they did that
right i promise you
well what my my thing is is does it
change if i just make the house payment
and then two weeks later make an
additional payment does that drop the
interest rate
or the um you know the interest once a
month down
once a month whatever you do in that
month
is going to affect the next month
so if you do if you do 10 extra payments
in a month it's only going to affect the
next month if you do one extra payment
in a month
equal to those 10 then it's going to
affect the interest rate the next month
exactly the same it's not calculated
daily it's calculated monthly
gotcha okay yeah i unfortunately i
haven't really done any of your baby
steps
but like i said i've right now i only
owe on my house
sounds like you have they just weren't
mine they were yours
they have no um
my credit i have one credit card and
it's frozen
because i froze it okay
um how much money do you have
huh how much money do you have in the
bank before you start paying this these
extra money
this time ten thousand just a little
over ten thousand dollars in my savings
i have a little over i think it's 75 000
in my roth
401k how old are you
63. good for you what do you make
um right about 45 yeah
you've done very well very yeah and just
continue to concentrate
i'd raise that emergency fund up a
little bit and i definitely want you to
invest more aggressively
not just pay extra on the house i want
you to be continuing to add
i want that 75 000 to go way up in the
next few years okay yeah
okay you've done really good you've done
i mean she's done a lot with
a single lady making 43. yeah yeah i was
about to say the same thing
wow this is i'm shocked
well that sounds bad yeah you're doing a
great job i'm very proud of her
yeah excellent job yeah yeah i mean
she's been fighting a
a tough battle probably there absolutely
so okay
here's the calculation here's the
calculation uh let's pretend you had for
calculation purposes an easy number is
three percent on your mortgage
okay that's that's a a quarter of a
percent
a month divide three by 12. okay so how
much per
month is your interest if you have three
percent annually
three divided by 12 is a quarter of a
percent yes okay a month
that is going to be calculated on how
much principal you
owe at the end of that month a quarter
times .0025
yeah okay remember me zero zero and
so if you've reduced the principal that
next month more of your payment
is going to go to principal and less to
interest because your interest will be
less
that following month with a traditional
fha va or conventional mortgage that's
how it'll work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
robin is with us in colorado springs hi
robin how can we help
hi anthony andes i'm calling on behalf
of my elderly parents who are in a
financial pickle
and need help on how to advise them they
have a three hundred and twenty thousand
dollar paid for
home but no savings and no retirement
um ninety eight thousand dollar heloc
eleven thousand in credit card debt
and their monthly income is about four
thousand uh expenses are about thirty
two hundred
so my father wants to get a hundred and
twenty five thousand dollar
mortgage to pay off all of his debts
and i know that's not what you would
advise dave
so how can i help them
how old are they early 80s
how's their health it's good
my father works a part-time job and
earns about 1100 a month
doing that in addition to the four or
the four is the total
the four is the total okay
well it's likely that um you don't need
a hundred and
twenty thousand dollar mortgage it looks
like it's a hundred and nine well
yeah yeah yeah that was 109 isn't it
yes so why the other 11 uh
i'm not sure probably just a
psychological
cushion of some kind and what would it i
would guess his payment would be less on
that if he did that
than the current yes
monthly right now they're paying only on
the interest on the heloc and it's about
325.
oh so it would the payment would go up
then
well right yes so i'm not even sure if
they could afford the payment so why
does he want the payment to go up
well that's a good question i don't know
that he's thought about that
all right um
this is your dad and your mom yes it's
not mine
um but mathematically
from a an actuarial table which is what
a life insurance company uses to rate
probability of someone passing away
mathematically really what we want to do
here is put something in place that they
can hang on
right it's not like we're going to turn
the corner on this and they're going to
move into prosperity
it's just to keep them from having to
move out of their house right
yes so i guess the question is what
gives them
the most room in their budget
and keeps them from having to move out
of their house is it remaining where we
are
or is it um getting a hundred and
ten thousand dollar mortgage no we're
not going to borrow more
and um so uh but but
i
you know you can run the numbers both
ways but i bet that heloc is going to be
cheaper monthly
yeah you're not making any progress but
i'm not really trying to make progress
at this stage of the game right
yeah i'm really just trying to let them
stay in their home okay i'm from an
emotional standpoint
because they you know anything we do
that makes it harder for them to stay in
the home
seems kind of wrong doesn't it yeah
and it's all about cash flow at this
stage of the game
so i'm probably that heloc may have a
variable rate and it may have a call on
it
and that could be dangerous if it has
like a three-year call and suddenly the
mortgage company decides they want all
their money
right that might put him in a pinch he
might be thinking about that call that
balloon
payment that's coming up on that thing
or he may be concerned interest rates
will go up in pricing out of the market
so
i guess i would dig into it and go okay
if we get a mortgage exactly what is the
payment going to be
if we don't get a mortgage what's the
payment going to be that's number one
because i want to minimize the payment
which is weird for dave ramsey to say
because the goal here is not really to
get it paid off the goal here is to let
them stay in their home
yeah because in five years statistically
you know we're not going to be dealing
with this right right
uh that was cold i'm sorry but i
understand
but it's just a math thing it's not just
a math thing it's anything but just a
math thing but i'm trying to think
mom and dad i want them to enjoy the
last five to ten years or whatever it is
by not having to move them i mean if we
were trying to prosper
we would move down into a house and pay
cash for it
if we were trying to prosper right yeah
but this is just
protecting their their standard of
living and letting them stay there and
pay the minimum payment i don't know
anthony
thoughts nah dave i'm right there with
you uh i'll tell you the
use this credit card's bothering me they
got to cut those things up and that
means they're not on a budget
yeah and they haven't stopped the
bleeding
that's exactly right yeah and he he's
and then he's trying to borrow his way
out of debt and that also indicates he's
not stopped the bleeding
and so we do need to get if we're going
to go with my plan
it really is not a good plan if they're
going to continue to dig the hole
yeah because
if he goes and gets 110 dollar mortgage
hundred twenty thousand dollar mortgage
and they don't contin they don't quit
overspending they're gonna be right back
here in three years two years
that's exactly right and i've i've tried
to tell them that but it's
it's uh hard to get that way across
so you know the the the biggest thing is
you have to stop
the the the over spending spend it you
you have to
if 4k is 4k is 4k you're not in congress
you need to live on 4k including these
payments
and cut the credit cards up and never
use them again and get debit cards
and live on a written budget with your
spouse and otherwise dad you need to
sell the house
and you need to move down in house and
that might be the cattle prod statement
like
you know like if you're not gonna quit
over spending you're gonna lose the
house
but you know because that you know
they're not i don't know how how long
how long over what period time do you
think they ran up that 11k
oh goodness uh probably just a few
months
they got this heloc uh not
not more than maybe two years ago
okay he cannot go get a new mortgage
yeah even if it's cheaper
because it's a pattern of him trying to
borrow his way out
they keep overspending and then they go
get another loan they overspend then
they go get another loan
and then we are sure we go get another
loan we go get another loan we go get
another loan
they have to stop the overspending so i
would say don't get a mortgage
because it's a continuation of this
negative pattern here
yeah okay i have i honestly have no idea
where
all that money went yeah
well they they're probably spending six
thousand bucks a month
yeah and so now the next question is
relationally how are you going to get
your uh
foot this far in the door to have these
right have this because you're gonna
have to sit down and do a budget with
them if you're gonna help them fix this
and you're gonna have to point out
to your mom or whoever it is that can't
stay out of freaking target that this
has got to stop
yeah you you've got the right person
pointed out there oh
and dad's trying to dad's trying to take
care of her dad's a band-aid
yeah he's an enabler right okay
well i think it'd be a great thing if if
you guys can get
create a conversation where there's a
budget
and you're walking them through uh
putting the budget together with both of
them sitting there
and let her have the revelation that
she's getting ready to cause them to
lose their home if she doesn't stop this
crap
but that doesn't come from you making
that statement it comes from you
continuing to ask questions like
mama if you continue to do this how do
you think this is going to end
okay if you don't stay on this budget
mom do you realize that you're you're
gonna
the that we're gonna run out of money
can you see that and let her see the
actual numbers
people can feel numbers when they're
sitting and looking at them
in relation to what they're doing but
when she's just like over there
you know being her four-year-old self at
target then
that that's it's not in context
but when you put it in context with the
rest of the situation
it gives you a jolt does that make sense
yes
it does and so but again that's not with
you coming in there and shaming them
it's more you asking a bunch of
questions and put a bunch of facts in
front of them
and the facts will smack them upside the
head
that's a counseling technique let the
facts do the hard work
the emotional work on these on them it's
a very difficult conversation either 80
year old parents
it's very hard but it to the extent you
can get involved as to the extent this
is going to get fixed it's going to get
ugly
if it doesn't get fixed wow
[Music]
[Music]
so
our scripture of the day first
corinthians 9
24 do you not know that in a race all
the runners run
but only one receives the prize so run
that you may obtain it
teddy rose teddy roosevelt said it is
hard to fail
but it is worse never
to have tried to succeed
ronald is with us in new york city hi
ronald how are you
hey dave anthony thank you so much for
taking my call sure how can we help
so me and my wife are currently face
tackling death we're in babysit two and
we have a few expenses big expenses
coming up in the next few months
i graduated this past may with your
accounting and i started
my salary 70 000 and my wife and i
got married this past august and we're
expecting a baby in the next four months
yay congrats a lot going on man
and the other other expense another
thing is uh we don't
own a car but we live in new york city
we always went through a train so once
we have
before the baby arrives we're looking to
get a car so i'm struggling to um
you have any money uh so i have 18 000
saved up oh that's good
i have 42 000 student loans i start with
forty two thousand i have thirty one
thousand
and my wife uh doesn't have any student
loans fully she has full scholarship
and she's currently in school she
doesn't work so i'm the only one
working currently
so i don't know how much to save
like how does it work how much the tax
was that how much do one
save up i'm sorry how much debt did you
say you had
currently 31 000. and you have 18 000
cash
and you have no car because you've been
using public transportation and now with
a baby you don't want to
yeah so when i needed a call my parents
lived 30 minutes away by public
transportation
so i would take their car okay so what
um
help me with your lifestyle situation on
when you would actually utilize the car
how much would it be used
so since i'm working from home and
it won't be used as much i mean it would
mainly be used
when you had the baby in the car correct
and where would you be taking said baby
[Laughter]
either to the doctors or i've been told
by a few friends that you've been
going to the doctors a few times and
also
usually we go out for the weekend by
family
so it might be driven five times a month
yeah
grocery shopping i'll use it at night at
night i'll be using it more
yeah but you don't have to have it for
that you were going at nights
to go on public transportation if it's
you
that's right so the actual need for the
car
is about five trips a month
correct around that around that yeah
because of the baby
correct yeah otherwise you were doing
fine without it because most
lots of people in new york city do not
own cars it's not that unusual at all
i know several people don't even have
driver's license that live there so
um uh yeah so you know what i'm gonna
buy
is a minimal car that's gonna start when
i need to start
but it doesn't really need to be that
much about 5 000 bucks
absolutely and 5 000 is generous i was
going to say about 3 500.
and then when baby comes you need to get
the rest of that money towards the debt
and let's get this debt cleared up yeah
so
what's the uh recommended amount that
you guys say when it comes to when
you're expecting baby to save up
all you can yeah all you can yeah and so
but you're you're in an unusual
situation part of you having a baby is
you need this car
yes and so yeah i would take five
of the 18 and or less and buy a car
a a reliable minivan
or four-door car of some kind whatever
you want to get
and uh you can get a lot of car for 5000
if you'll shop carefully
uh where are you going to park this
thing
so i don't really live in new york city
i live in brooklyn okay
so it's much more easier compared to new
york city
yes yes that's gonna because i mean a
stinking parking spot
in the city can in manhattan can be more
than an apartment yes
okay that's good so five thousand
dollars man
that's your that's your max yeah okay
what the if you spend more than that let
me tell you what you did you used your
baby as an excuse to buy a car you
wanted
yes because your need for this
car is five trips a month that's your
actual need
and i really think about this 15 18 000
for a car
until me and my wife decided after
listening to we just started listening
to you
to go towards your dead right correct
okay after the baby comes yes so i'd buy
a car for 5 000 i'd leave the 13 sitting
there i'd pile up as much as i can pile
up on top of that
and then when baby comes i would take it
down to a thousand bucks and restart
your baby steps and attack that debt
and then let's get the rest of that 30
000 bucks it'll be about 15 at that
point cleaned off
and uh as fast as you can get it cleaned
off and then once that's cleaned off you
build your emergency fund your work and
your baby
steps but yeah i get the car i get the
car purchase and i'm not
you know but just don't use this as an
excuse to buy an 18 000 car which is
what you were about to do you said
earlier
and then you stumbled into the youtube
or or podcast world or something and
uh and we interrupted your plan
[Laughter]
so it is a different um
uh world where there's that kind of
public transportation and where it's
quite the norm
yes it is uh versus most major cities in
america you wouldn't even
be having this conversation yeah you
would need a car but new york
yeah yeah but uh but that that's uh
very interesting eighteen thousand
dollars at his age i'm i'm pleased with
him
brittany's in houston hi brittany how
can we help hi david anthony thank you
guys for taking my call
sure um my husband and i have
a fully funded six-month emergency fund
and we have no debt
except for our mortgage which we still
owe 86
000 on okay um we are saving 15
of our income to retirement okay and
right now we're working on paying our
house off early okay
um i was actually just offered a new job
in a new city that's out of state
but it's a temporary position for the
fellowship so it's two to three years
and so we only plan on renting while
we're there
not buying a house or anything um we
really don't know where we'll end up
after that two to three year period
and so my question is whether really
what we should do with our current house
whether we should keep it
and rent it out which based off of comps
in the area
would be about 1800 a month or if we
should sell it and pocket the money
and uh you know invest that what's your
fellowship
uh in molecular virology
say one more time um uh
virology so i study viruses okay all
right
and so obviously you're a medical doctor
yeah
i'm a phd okay so you're doing research
it's research fellowship okay good good
for you and there's no for sure chance
you're coming back to your
current stadium no not a chance yeah not
when she finishes that
we're going to be super valuable um
i think you need to concentrate 100 on
the fellowship not on being a landlord
yeah okay i think your
your focus should be singular uh this is
an important opportunity for you
it's beyond important and it's a beyond
it's actually quite an honor as well
yeah you obviously have an incredible
intellect
and uh so yeah i i don't want this
distraction
of some idiot changing his harley oil in
your living room back in houston while
you're on the other side of the country
so we're trying to work on saving the
world yeah from viruses
and um so no i think we need you
focusing on your fellowship all of us do
absolutely i agree so yeah i i would
sell it if i were in your shoes you'll
get a
plenty nice house when you do make the
final
location that you're going to land in
that's
long-distance landlording bad plan i
wouldn't do it
not even considering it yeah not even
good stuff but thank you for what you're
doing though
we absolutely we need we need more of
you
absolutely and good analysis on hey
we're only going to be there for a
couple years so we're going to rent
there that's a good
that was a good decision already having
already made that going in
now with it will she be able to stay
stable though when she finds
that oh yeah yeah when she finishes that
that's going to just increase her value
in the marketplace
dramatically wow yeah pretty impressive
good stuff that puts this hour in the
books thanks anthony o'neil james childs
and kelly daniel in the booth i am dave
ramsey we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there
is ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
you